Hey guys, remember ShamWow?
That hyper-absorbent towel hawked by the overeager ShamWow guy?
Well, it turns out
That ShamWow was just a smelly hand mop, and the ShamWow guy?
He got bit by a prostitute and then got arrested for punching her.
Where am I going with all this?
Donald Trump is the ShamWow guy of presidents. He's selling Americans on a presidency
that's dangerously ineffective, but he does it so so well
Newsbroke viewers know Trump is a crap businessman and that unless you staff them with llamas,
there's no excuse for bankrupting casinos.
But being bad at running a business doesn't mean you're a bad salesman.
It just means your bamboozler, a swindler, a big beautiful bullish*t artist.
And Trump's really good at selling things.
He's been doing it for years.
We eat our pizza the wrong way.
Crust first.
So what do you think of my trump home mattress collection by Serta?
A Big and Tasty for just a dollar?
How do you do it? What's your secret?
How are you president?
What makes a good salesman? Knowing how to play on human psychology.
Social psychologist Robert Cialdini goes over the following manipulative sales tactics in his book, Influence.
And they are eerily familiar.
One is called "liking": making yourself likable by being
unavoidable. Research has found that when a person's face is constantly flashed on screen,
subjects instinctively come to like that person more.
Right guys?
Love me....
And Trump knows all about screen time.
His campaigns focused on a total saturation of news coverage and spent way more time than Hillary Clinton
traveling around the country doing large rallies.
And he's used to that kind of overexposure because he's literally been putting his name on everything for years.
Specifically symbols of wealth, like big buildings and golf courses, to make his name
synonymous with money.
Just like George Foreman's name was synonymous with grilling
and Bill Cosby's name was synonymous with Jell-O.
Remember what it was Jell-O?
Another way to get people to buy your product is with "social proof,"
a phenomenon that says that people look to others to make
decisions. So a salesperson doesn't have to convince us directly that their product is good,
they just need to say that others think it's good.
Lysol is the number one brand.
I'm number one in the polls.
Because it's America's number one brand.
Now I'm number one in every single poll.
America's number one brand.
Number one in every single place.
I'm number one in the polls
I'm the number one NBA draft pick. I'm the number one Latin recording artist of 2013 in Miami Beach (laughs)
And then there's the principle of "Authority," real or imagined.
We're trained from birth to think that authority is good.
So when someone with credentials tells you their product is legit,
you generally believe it. And credentials might mean whichever guy is wearing a suit.
Take it from the guy who for decades
just wore a suit.
You're gonna like the way you look. I guarantee it.
I guarantee it.
You're going to like the way you look. I guarantee it.
Maybe it's the suit, maybe it's the beard, or maybe it's that little model ship
he keeps in his pretend home.
But something makes me trust him. Or maybe it's that word ...
I guarantee
and I guarantee you
I guarantee you
I guarantee
a hundred percent
Here that? He just guaranteed it. I don't know what it is, but I'll take it.
Racism? Aw...
So it's pretty terrifying to realize that the same way Trump sold himself on the campaign trail--
See I understand the tax cut better than anybody that's ever run for president
I understand the world much better than he does.
I understand things I comprehend very well
--is exactly how he sold America on his steaks.
"I understand steaks it's my favorite food and these are the best
"I understand it because it's my favorite food"?!
OK, but steak is also Scout's favorite food.
But guess what? She's a f*cking dog. She understands nothing.
The thing is, Trump knows he's a bullsh*t artist
Take Trump University, the fake real estate workshops that allegedly defrauded nearly 3800 clients
who Trump just settled with for $25 million.
Trump University actually had a Trump University  playbook,
a manual given out to instructors to lead these seminars that
specifically advised them to do the following things:
only focus on the benefits of the program,
catalog objections and build rebuttals to any criticism,
and never give prospective clients details
about the program. And by following the playbook,
instructors like this guy became the University's top seller.
James Harris's job was to get people to believe they too could be as successful at real estate as Donald Trump.
Do you remember when you said this? "I'm a former licensed agent broker. At 29,
I became the top 1% broker in the country.
I build homes in Atlanta, Georgia, and I used to live in Beverly Hills."
Yes, I...
if I said those things then they are true.
I did live in Beverly Hills and--
-We have no record of you ever living in Beverly Hills.
Okay.
We can't find your
broker's license anywhere.
Okay.
And I have no idea
what homes you built in Atlanta, Georgia. You build homes in Georgia?
I'm not prepared to answer those questions today.
That is unless you'll let me consult the playbook one second ...
That guy was their top seller, so it's no wonder many attendees wound up feeling like this:
I started getting upset feeling that this was not an actual learning seminar
but maybe just an upselling seminar. I tried to get my money back and
two other instructors were brought over and basically
cornered me telling me that I just didn't understand the material.
Focus on the benefits, deflect criticism,
be vague on the details, and corner your opponents.
The art of the bullshit. Or the art of the Trump administration.
Because instead of guys who definitely did not live in Beverly Hills,
Trump's instructors are now his team of well-heeled mouthpieces
who painstakingly and purely focus on Trump's benefits.
Our president is a man with broad shoulders
and a big heart.
Wait what?
From his first day in office
he's been keeping his promises to the American people.
Promise number 1: lock her---uhh
Promise number 2:
drain the swa..
Promise number 3: don't bomb Syria...uhh
Like Trump University salesmen, Trump's advisors also preempt any criticism, and then deflect deflect deflect.
Isn't it irresponsible for a president elect to make false statements like that?
I think it's groundless-- talk about fake news, the fake news
is that somehow the popular vote is more important than the Electoral college vote now.
Kelly Anne, that's not what I asked, no one's questioning
No, one's no one is questioning the victory.
Oh, but that's not the point George. the point is Kellyanne said fake news twice.
You lose.
And these salesmen/shills
keep the facts real vague.
Like Sean Spicer all the time. Even when he's asked pointedly if Trump knows the unemployment rate.
He's not focused on
statistics as much as he is on whether or not the American people are
doing better as a whole.
You see you people need to understand something: Trump is like a Magic Eye poster.
You need to stand way back,
cross your eyes for a solid four years and just don't blink and eventually
you'll get it.
What happened to Trump University is happening to this country.
Trump is not going to be able to deliver on his promise to a very white America.
Already his health care bill failed, a new travel ban is held up in court
and Mexico most certainly will not pay for the border wall.
So for some final advice on being a good salesman, let's remember:
"You can't con people at least not for long. You can create excitement,
you can do wonderful promotion and get all kinds of press, and you can throw in a little hyperbole.
But if you don't deliver on the goods people will eventually catch on.
Thanks Mr. ShamWow president. We will catch on. Sham Now or Sham Later
"Location also is allowed to do is fashion. You can take a mediocre
location and turn it into something considerably better just by attracting the right people" ... like Newsbroke.
We've attracted you, you're the right people. Huh won't you subscribe you've gotten this far
What's it to you?